no cameras in here carry focus she's
just told the whole world that dad David
cancer mom needs to tell him the truth
before someone else does I know you
should talk to her
what why me because you're chases
assistant now so if you are way better
at having difficult conversations with
mom remember when you told her you were
gay you told her I was gay I mean who
can remember who told what when she
found weed in your purse so you said
Carrie's gay well in that case it's your
turn okay you guys like that song you're
gonna love this next one because it's
the same plus horns I don't know the sex
of these things this is small gross
how were you not freaking out right now
about what chase just made his entire
album about cancer and he did not have a
dad that died of cancer so it's still
nice whoo what are you saying you don't
want your brother raising money for
cancer that's pretty low carry no I
don't want my little brother labeled a
liar well no one knows the truth except
for our family well in the hospital the
Lisa from down the street
she's when I brought me the blow dryer
oh my god mom but it's not lying
anywhere even his obituary said cancer
so this can just be like our new family
history that's not fair to chase
I mean he's only said cancer once okay
guys I've got another surprise this fall
I'm going on to her and 10% of the
proceeds will also go to the American
Cancer Society
[Applause]
you're doing it you're fighting cancer
hey Julie can I just talk to you in the
bathroom for a second listen is there
any way we had to tone down the whole
cancer thing absolutely not this is a
pure gold mine that's all we made sure
what any kid on this plane has cancer
they do wait no no no no we ended up not
doing X we don't want them coughing over
the music it's just it feels like
cancers been done before you know and
between you and me I feel like if we
were gonna solve cancer he really would
have by now it trust me but end of this
blitz chase will own cancer okay it's
just really hard to your cancer I'm
sorry
okay if you're gonna cry just get him
the live stream
[Music]
okay oh yeah yeah I just wanted to do
one of these yeah so what are you guys
talking about in here you making fun of
me what no no we're just dealing with a
family issue so oh good then come on lay
it on me man what what's what's the
issue all right because I consider you
guys family you and Brooke are like
grandparents too it's very nice but
we're just gonna handle this internally
say you know what I think might help
Helen I don't know you're pig okay all
the proceeds are going to stay with me
now now the first prize is sick how are
you I'm great ma'am would you like a
beverage very bunny
so no beverage then ma'am
are you joking it's me it's hug
have we met before yeah at the motel
by JFK I don't I ate your butt sorry
guys this next item is the chance to be
a part of my next music video because
I'll think of you as I film it
[Applause]
[Music]
mom what are you doing out there I
thought Kerry talked to you he did talk
to me we both decided we're not gonna
tell chase the truth Oh mom I know that
you'd like to chase to protect him but
you could really hurt him well if you
two wanted you know so bad that why
don't you tell him because I'm not his
mom mom I like basically have been for
the last six months it's hot in here
come on
don't change the subject okay here's
what we're gonna do we're not gonna do
cheese I'm starting tomorrow my name is
Roberta your Felicia carries Dante
chases Miguel we moved to South America
we start over
what Oh God
also Felicia thanks cutie so Chase is
still going very hard and the whole
cancer thing have you not told him no
she hasn't
how about this we crashed the plane mom
not into a building Carrie into a field
so only we die mom no well I don't see
you pitching any ideas I'm just saying
if john slattery was our thing to do
with them out it's the grounds crew and
they are probably all men okay I've
decided I'm not telling chase none of us
are that's my final answer
well I says that feels so heavy no mommy
they need to be smaller when we saw
you